[Musica]
le ragazze
è da tutti ragazzi ebbene tutto questo
nuovo video sono fa vj ed oggi siamo
sullo speciale 250 mila iscritti
ciao ragazzi voi credete soltanto che
questo speciale sia arrivato in ritardo
ma in realtà non è così è perché
utilizzo internet explorer tra l'altro
ragazzi nel frattempo che dovevo uscire
lo speciale siamo arrivati a 320.000 una
cosa del genere quindi ragazzi è
veramente incredibile ma ma di quello vi
parlerò nello speciale di domani perché
questo è dedicato a 250.000 quindi
facciamo finta di non aver raggiunto
alti traguardi poi domani vedremo per i
prossimi quindi ragazzi preparatevi per
lo speciale anche di domani perché è una
cosa che non ho mai fatto in vita mia
quindi tenetevi pronti a questi ragazzi
non è da meno perché era una cosa che
volevo fare da tempo da quando per i
mentori g oggi la toseland air nella
vita reale ed è da quel momento ragazzi
che ha sempre voluto fare un videogame
divertente nella vita reale perché
appunto svendere un è un horror e come
video che in divertenti cianotico su
motori quei quelli classici che faccio
io è più mi sgolo è più vi sarà
impossibile da fare nella vita dare un
casino e allora dopo averci pensato
tantissimo ho trovato è praticamente
l'unico fattibile era proibite
scribblenauts che comunque è stato
difficilissimo da fare nonostante
ragazzi il video sia uscita abbastanza
corto e mi scuso mi scuso tantissimo per
questo però ragazzi vi assicuro che per
far uscire questo ci ho messo un
eternità nonostante sia non sia
lunghissimo perché è pieno zeppo di
effetti e vedrete tra poco perché è un
casino ha quindi ragazzi vi ringrazio di
cuore per il traguardo la giovane
ringraziare di cuore chi mi ha dato una
mano nel realizzare lo speciale perché
da sola non ci sarei mai riuscito a
quella aiuto li tantissimi altri
youtuber che rilasci canali tutti in
descrizione che sono prime bau rizio
valente che ringrazio tantissimo perché
se si è sbattuto evitare tutto lascio
anche il suo ghana lin descrizione
ragazzi andate a vederlo perché dopo
tutto il casino che ha fatto se mostra
merita dopodiché anche i canali di
stregata che che ha partecipato al video
e infine ringrazio di cuore riccardo
alessandro perché nelle riprese sono
stati fantastici e cosa non ti qualcosa
ragazzi la più importante di tutte che
nello speciale utilizzato questo questa
è la cosa più [ __ ] che io abbia mai
avuto in tutta la mia vita
nuova rete moretta temi che cazzo ma che
cazzo di mira di merda ciò
vabbè ragazzi vi lascio il video spero
vivamente che vi piaccia
quindi ragazzi mettetevi comodi e
preparatevi ad entrare nel mondo di
script
[Musica]
per avere una bella storia basta avere
pochi elementi dei colori sgargianti è
un bel protagonista
poi se mettiamo che il protagonista è in
possesso di un quaderno magico che gli
permette di materializzare qualsiasi
cosa tutto diventa più divertente ma non
sarebbe una storia come si deve
se non ci fosse anche un antagonista va
bene basta raccontare
andiamo all'azione tutti di essere
all'altezza dell'ultimo inverno
[Musica]
la tranquilla non andrò via senza la mia
nutella
mi sento solo ha bisogno di compagnia
troppo facile
[Musica]
non escludo
ok
[Musica]
tu pensi di essere all'altezza
dell'ultimo appello e so forse più
difficile
questo non te lo aspettavi
cosa diavolo posso fare che
sottoscrivere
qualsiasi cosa faccia lui la replica
[Musica]
mi arrendo hai vinto
io vorrei
[Musica]
ma dei ragazzi spero che vi sia piaciuto
ci abbiamo messo una vita nonostante
fosse corto ma ci abbiamo messo
tantissimo è stata una delle esperienze
più belle che abbia mai passato perché
tra l'altro registrare a perché poi a
voi non sembrava ma c'erano meno 14
gradi si gelava e dovevo registrare con
la felpa senza giubbotto è stato un
suicidio quindi ragazzi ogni mi piace è
un termosifone in più veramente vi
ringrazio per il traguardo raggiunto è
stato fantastico registrare questo
speciale è stato divertentissimo ci
siamo divertiti parecchio nonostante ciò
che faceva un freddo cane ogni tanto
nelle riprese passava la gente dietro
quindi è stato un casino ma nonostante
questo ce l'abbiamo fatta sono
orgogliosissimo del risultato e
ringrazio era mente tutti coloro che
hanno partecipato perché è stato
stupendo vi ricorda anche che domani
esce lo speciale dei 300.000 iscritti
che è veramente un video al quale tengo
tantissimo quindi la gara non
permetterlo perché sarà una delle cose
più fantastiche che vedrete e ve lo
posso garantire
pd ragazzi sei lì dove è piaciuto come
solito lasciato un commento mi piace
anche la pagina di facebook che come noi
video trovata una descrizione senza che
gli scritti iscrivetevi ci rivediamo
lucroso sensi l'eco iscritti iscrivetevi
non ci rivediamo in un prossimo vi do
una porca [ __ ] e riuscire vediamo 1
grosseto seznec rischi discrete vini ci
rivediamo un prossimo video ragazzi